[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARAN BHATIA: So my
name is Karan Bhatia.
I'm a solutions
architect with Google.
And I lead our efforts
around scientific computing.
And I'm here with
a distinguished set
of panelists, Matteo Chinazzi,
Salvador Dura-Bernal,
Ben Torkian, Paul Sagona.
And what we have for you
today is a panel session
about how people are
leveraging Google
Cloud for doing
scientific computing
and for research computing.
It's really a great time
for scientific computing.
It's really exciting to be a
computational scientist today.
The access to new
processors, new accelerators,
and new software
frameworks are really
enabling the
researchers to harness
a large amount of
compute capability
and really putting it at their
fingertips to advance science.
The Google Cloud has
a worldwide system.
We have built it on
a global network that
includes everything from
the fiber optic cables
to the servers to data storage.
We have 17 regions
distributed around the world.
We have thousands of point
of presence sites, undersea
cables, and submarines.
And yes, we have
sharks that bite.
I don't know-- you might have
heard that we have sharks that
bite the fiber optic cables, and
we have to go down and fix it.
So all of that is
owned by Google.
And those-- that capability
with 17 regions around the world
is really made
available to everybody,
including the academic
research community.
So some of the things that we do
for the scientific community--
so the first thing is that
we have a pretty robust set--
free tier of services
for our products.
So not only do you get--
when you sign up, you get, I
think, about $300 in credits
to use generally, but
most of the products
themselves have a free tier.
So for example, if
you're using BigQuery,
you can use a certain amount
of BigQuery every single month,
a certain amount of
GKE and other services.
Every service has a free tier.
And that's a great way
of exploring, and using,
and learning about
the Google Cloud
Platform for your research.
If you need more than that, we
have a research credit program,
where we would--
we can provide some
more credits for you
to leverage Google Cloud
for your research needs.
And we're working
very extensively
with the funding agencies
to make it really easy
to allow you to get funding--
get Google Cloud Credits
for your research,
your multi-research--
your research projects.
We've had a really strong
collaboration with the National
Science Foundation.
And we continue that with
building more programs
and more interactions there.
And earlier this week, we
announced a collaboration
with a partnership with the
National Institutes of Health
as well.
So across the board
where we're really
making it as easy as possible
for scientific and research
computing to be done
with Google Cloud.
And to show you guys what people
have done with this, please--
well, let me-- before we
bring the speakers up,
there was one more thing.
There is a National Science
Foundation report that just
came out that talked this--
there was a workshop in
January that brought together
a lot of academics.
This was run by Jennifer
Rexford in Princeton University.
And it talked about
how to facilitate
Google Cloud for academic
use and why to do that.
So there's a number
of recommendations
there within that
report for universities
and for academic departments.
I encourage you guys
to take a look at that.
So please join me
in welcoming Matteo
to talk about his research and
how he's leveraging the Google
Cloud for his science.
[CLAPPING]
MATTEO CHINAZZI:
Hello, Everybody.
Thank you, Karan,
for the introduction,
and it's great to be here.
So I would like to start my
presentation off by asking you
one simple question.
What will you do if
somebody came to you
and asked you to
model mosquito bites?
Well, that was our
task back in 2016.
And in this
presentation, I'm going
to tell you how we developed
a model with the help of GCP
to study the diffusion of
Zika virus across the globe.
And just to give
you some context--
so back in 2015, Brazil had
notified the World Health
Organization that a
new mysterious virus
was circulating in the country.
And a few months
later, that virus
was recognized to be Zika.
And moreover, during
the same year,
they also noticed
an unusual increase
in the number of microcephaly
cases in the country.
And for the ones of you that are
not familiar with microcephaly,
it is a rare
neurological condition
in which kids-- infants heads
are significantly smaller
than they once of other
kids of the same age of sex.
It may cause not only physical
but also learning disabilities
as newborns grow.
So because of this,
there was soon
suspected that a link exists
between the appearance of Zika
virus in Brazil and microcephaly
and other congenital
neurological conditions.
And for this reason, the WHO
declared in February 2016
a public health emergency
of international concern.
And that's actually
why we decided to start
working into this project.
So our goal was
essentially to try
to develop a model that
could help public health
officials to better understand
the evolution and the dynamic
of the Zika outbreak
across the world.
And by the time we
were done not only
we have done just that, but
actually we have developed
a new platform, a new framework
that would allow us to study
also other diseases as
I will tell you later
on that year of
this presentation.
So now let me tell
you how we did it.
In the next few
minutes, I'm going
to talk to you
about three things.
First, I'm going
to tell you what
were the scientific and
computational challenges
that we faced and
how we overcame them.
Then I'm going to tell you what
are the main lessons to learn
well using GCP in our journey.
And at the end, I
will give you a taste
of the kind of
scientific results
that we can obtain
using our model.
But before diving into
the scientific challenges,
let me take a step back and
give you a piece of good news.
So luckily for us, at
our labs and thanks also
to our network of
collaborators, we
have access to a
team of experts that
know how to model
contagious outbreaks
and in particularly
at MOBS lab, we
have a long expediency
modeling anything
from the seasonal flu to Ebola.
And actually one of the
things that we do best
is to develop computational
and analytical models to study
the special spread of diseases.
And at the core,
at the foundation
of many of our work
projects, we have
GLEAM, which is our Global
Epidemic and Mobility
Model that essentially allows
us to simulate and track
the evolution of an
epidemic across the world
from beginning to end.
So let me just spend one minute
telling you how GLEAM works.
GLEAM essentially is
a piece of software
that allows you to
combine different data
sources, high-resolution
census data, mobility data
and complex disease dynamics
into a unified framework.
And the way it works
is that it makes
use of this high-resolution
population data
to divide the world into
different subpopulations, which
are then connected to each other
through a mobility network,
that for example take
into account for the fact
that people daily commute to
go to work or take airplanes
to travel.
And then what the
model does is that it
takes each subpopulation
and simulated the diffusion
of a virus within that
subpopulation while
taking into account for all the
possible interconnections that
exist between them because
of the mobility network.
So essentially what
GLEAM allows us to do
is to simulate the
evolution of an epidemic
at the global scale.
Unfortunately, though for us,
when we started this project,
there was one thing that
GLEAM was not able to do.
And that was model
mosquito bites.
So the first thing
that we had to do
was to introduce, first of
all, a mathematical model that
could allow us to model
mosquitoes within GLEAM.
And second, we had to introduce
additional data sources
within the computational
framework of GLEAM
actually to indeed
model mosquito presence
in biting patterns.
And the reason why
we have to do that is
because the main drivers of
Zika transmissions are infected
mosquitoes that by
biting individuals inject
the virus within a population.
And then those same
individuals in turn,
when they are bitten by
otherwise healthy mosquitoes,
they can help propagate
dividers back to--
back to the mosquitoes,
and then the cycle goes on.
However, not only we
had to, as I said,
add the new mathematical
model within GLEAM,
but we also had to add
new data sources together
with the population
and mobility data
that we already had to
account for different things.
The first one is that
we had to introduce
very detailed mosquito
maps telling us
where around the world
there are mosquitoes
that are able to actually
carry Zika virus.
Then we also had to add monthly
varying temperature data
to actually model
mosquito life cycles--
so mosquito lives and deaths.
And then on top of
that, we also to add
socio-economic indicators
to account for the fact
that if you live in an
area where you have access
to better sanitation
facilities or simply there
is a more widespread
use of air conditioning,
then you are less subject
to be bitten by a mosquito
and therefore of
contracting Zika.
After we have done all of
that-- however, all of this,
however, we are not
done, because there
were other challenges
that we had to face.
First and foremost,
we did not know
the [INAUDIBLE] original time
and place of introduction
of Zika virus in Brazil.
And that essentially
meant that we
didn't know from where and when
to start our simulations from.
Plus, since now we have
additional complexity,
in our model we have many
more additional parameters
that we need to calibrate,
because not only we
have to trace and
simulate people movements,
but also mosquito presence
in biting patterns.
And obviously, since
it was the first time
we were doing
something like this,
we also would like to have
a computational framework
and pipeline to allow us
to have quick iterations
between different
versions of our model.
So all those problems actually
translate pretty directly
in some very specific
computational challenges
that we have to address.
The first one is
that since we did not
know the original time of
the introduction of the virus
in Brazil, we had to run
longer simulations with GLEAM
to essentially explore back
in the past what was going on.
And that meant that each single
simulation of a global epidemic
will take up to seven
minutes on average to run.
However, because of the
randomness that we have
and the complexity that
we have in the model,
we actually have to run
200,000 of those simulations
to have robust results.
And that, unfortunately for us,
generates about 25 terabytes
of data that then
we have to process.
And as I said, we would
like to do all of this--
run the simulations-- and
analyze the results quickly--
meaning in less of a day.
And that's essentially where
GCP came in to save the day
and help us with our research.
So what is the
cloud-based solution
that we devised to
address those challenges?
First of all, our
first stop was actually
to deploy GLEAM
on compute engine
to essentially help
us scale up in terms
of the number of parallel jobs
we could run at the same time.
And to give you
an idea that meant
that the peak research hours we
were using up to 30,000 cores
at the time.
Moreover, since we did not
want to actually saturate our
on prem NFS
partitions, we decided
to store from the very
beginning all our work
data and raw data
on cloud storage
and to use the power of
BigQuery to actually parse
all those terabytes
of data that we
were generating to have
essentially all our simulations
done and analyzed within a day.
And then our pipeline we
close essentially moving back
all the process data
to our local machines,
where we will generate then
the figures and the numbers we
want it to look
at, to analyze what
happened with our simulations.
But let me give you some
numbers to get an understanding
of the scale of our efforts.
So overall, we simulated
more than 10 million
global epidemics from
beginning to end.
And that amounted to
about-- to more actually
than 250 compute years.
And to run all the
simulations, we
deployed more than 450,000
instances in the compute engine
and analyzed more than 300
terabytes of data on BigQuery.
While doing this, we
learned a few things.
First off, we learned that in
order to save money actually
was better to move
from standard VM
to preemptibles,
because that essentially
allowed us to run five
simulations for the price
of one and to provide GLEAM--
so to provide our software,
for example, in
terms of memory usage
to then allow us to use
custom machines instead
of regular instances.
And in term of
time-saving, what we
found was that it was extremely
beneficial to actually
run many concurrent job,
loading job, in BigQuery
to drastically reduce
the amount of time
we had to wait to
actually populate
the database with all
the terabytes of data
that we were generating.
And last, but not least, we
automatized our entire pipeline
using the GCP client
library for Python
to allow us essentially to run
all the simulations plus all
the analyzes and
get to the very end,
the very nice PDF report with
all the numbers and figures
we wanted to look at without--
without human intervention.
So now let me give you a
taste of the kind of results
and the kind of things
we can do with this.
So first of all, we can use
GLEAM as our own personal time
machine to go back in the
past and try to figure out
what was the original time
and place of introduction
of dividers in Brazil.
And for example,
what you see there
is that we find that the most
probable time of introduction
was between September
2013 and February 2014.
But of course, what we
can do is that we can also
peek into the future.
So what we can do,
for example, is
to generate the very detailed
maps for a specific time
period telling us how
many Zika infections there
were in specific
places in the world.
And we can also,
since we are tracking
traveling within
our simulations,
account for how many
new cases of Zika
are imported because
of our traveling
to different countries and
then compare those data
with the ones that are
actually observed and collected
by local authorities, like for
example the CDC in this case.
So what's next for us?
Well, as I told you at the
beginning, our platform now
of course model Zika
virus, but in principle can
be used and extended
to study also
other vector-borne diseases, for
example, dengue, yellow fever,
and chikungunya.
Therefore, please stay
tuned to hear more from us
in the future regarding this.
But if in the meantime
you want to know
more about all our
other projects and all
the amazing people that
actually worked on this project,
please have a look
at our websites
where you can find more
information about this project
and all the other amazing
things we have been doing.
And thank you for
your attention.
I want to leave the
floor to Salvador
to tell you about how you can
stimulate the brain with GCP.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
SALVADOR DURA-BERNAL:
Hi, everyone.
So I want to start by
quoting President Obama.
Two years ago, he was
surprised that as human beings
we were able to understand
particle, subatomic particles.
We were able to understand
galaxies light years away,
but we were still
unable to understand
the brain, the
mysteries of the brain,
that three pounds of
matter between our ears,
which is basically
responsible for everything
that we experience and
everything that we do.
He knew this knowledge
could be transformative.
So he decided to start a massive
free research project called
the brain initiative,
which is over $4 billion,
to try to understand the brain.
Many other countries in the
world have done similar things.
And that's why
understanding the brain
is now considered
the new space race.
So today, I want to
talk about three things.
First, why study the
brain, why is it important,
how we can use simulations
to understand the brain,
and how will cloud help
to run these simulations.
So why study the brain?
The main motivation
for me was knowing
that one out of six people
suffers a brain disorder.
These range from depression,
anxiety, Parkinson's, epilepsy,
schizophrenia.
So this means that if you
count five people in you row,
one of you is likely to
have one of these disorders.
As an example, I
want to show you
what we can do to help
with these disorders.
So I'm going to show you a video
from "CBS 60 Minutes" magazine,
which shows a woman who's
paralyzed from the neck
downwards.
So she cannot move
any part of her body,
but she has an electrode
implanted in her brain.
So with these
electrodes, we can read
the signals of the motor cortex,
which controls the movements.
And then she is able
to move an arm almost
as if she wasn't paralyzed.
There's no sound,
but she's basically
explained that she can
move the arm up and down.
She can close the
fist, open the fits,
and she can now
even try to shake
the hand of the presenter.
The presenter is pretty
amazed that this can happen.
And now she offers
to do a fist bump.
This is obviously
pretty amazing.
And the reason this can
happen is that we actually
understand how some of
the signals in the brain
are encoded.
And we can use that
information to decode them.
But of course, there
are many things
that we can do now
to improve these.
As you saw, the
movements are not yet
very fluid, very smooth.
So there's many
things that we can do
to understand the brain better.
So how do simulations help
understanding the brain?
First, I want to start
explaining why the brain is
so complex to understand.
And the reason is that
there are many levels, which
are nested inside each other.
So this could be like an
analogy to nested Russian dolls.
So if you start from
the higher level,
you see that these
outer layer called
the cortex is sort of if
you stretch it out it would
be like the size of a pizza.
And it has many
different regions,
which have different
functions-- so for example,
to process vision,
to move your body.
So if you go and zoom into one
of these regions, what you see
is a very complex
circuit of neurons.
They are also structured
in different layers.
There's six layers of neurons.
And they process
all the information,
encode what you're doing.
And if you go even and zoom into
one of these single neurons,
you will see that this is
also a very complex machine.
So it has lots of chemical
processes going on,
lots of electrical activity.
And what's interesting
and complicated
is that these three
different levels
interact with each other.
So if you want to test something
at the molecular level--
so you, for example, try
an antidepressant drug,
an anti-epileptic
drug, caffeine--
you have to check what
happens at the single cell,
single neuron level.
That's going to affect the
circuit level, then in turn
the whole brain
oscillations, for example,
and finally, the behavior
of the human being.
So how can we make sense
of all this complexity?
So luckily for us, there's
been many years now
of experiments done
on the brain, both
measuring the shape of
neurons, how they're connected,
the function of the neurons.
And what we can
do with simulation
is try to put all
these together.
So here is an example
of a simulation
based on lots of experimental
data from many years.
And what we do is reproduce
as accurately as possible
the experimental
data that we have.
And then we can use
these models, which
are very similar
to the real brain,
to test experiment with,
for example, new treatments
to treat some of these
disorders that we saw.
The advantage of
having a simulation
is basically that you can
test as many combinations
as you need.
So in the real
brain it's very hard
to test different treatments,
because of ethics reasons.
So in the simulation, you can
do thousands of different tests
with different parameters,
different combinations.
So I'm going to show you an
example of some of the modeling
that I do.
It's centered in the motor
cortex, the part of the brain
that control most movements.
And here I'm showing
the basic level.
So this is a single neuron
from the motor cortex.
And it's important to model very
accurately the single neurons,
because they are basically the
building blocks of the brain.
So a single neuron can be
responsible for our perception.
It can be responsible
for moving an arm.
They integrate information
from lots of other neurons
and then perform functions.
The shape is an
important aspect.
So if you have the
wrong shape in a neuron,
for example, less branches,
that could lead to disorders
like Alzheimer's or if you have
a neuron that responds too much
electrically that
could lead to epilepsy.
So it's important to model
very accurately both the shape
as we see here.
On the left, we have
the experimental data.
That's an image
from 3D microscopy
and then the simulation
would just be very similar
and also the
electrical response.
So we have the
experimental data.
And we have this
simulation, which is, again,
very similar to the original.
So to simulate these
neurons, we use
a very detailed mathematical
model, which implies--
requires solving
differential equations,
hundreds of differential
equations every millisecond.
And it basically calculates
the currents and the voltages
at every point of the neuron.
So this was an example for a
single neuron, but what I do
is simulate a circuit.
So I simulate a
tissues, a brain tissue
of around the size
of a grain of salt,
which includes 10,000 neurons--
as detailed as the
one I showed before--
and over 30 million connections.
So these connections are
based on experimental data.
They depend on the
cell type on the layers
where they're positioned.
They have inputs
from other regions.
And using this model,
we can now check
how information is processed,
encoded in these circuits.
And we can also test all these
different drugs and treatments.
So that's an example of how much
computing power this requires.
One second of the simulation
with 10,000 neurons and 30
million connections requires
around one hour in 50 cores
of the supercomputer.
So how do they use Google
Cloud to simulate the brain?
So I mentioned one of the
simulations required 50 cores.
But of course, we need to run
thousands of these simulations.
Why?
First, because we need to
optimize the model to reproduce
the real brain biology.
So we have to run many
parameter combinations
to check that our
model actually that's
what the real brain does.
And secondly, once we have
a model which is actually
close to the real brain, we can
use it to experiment with it.
We can, for example, there's
all these treatments--
test also electrical
stimulation treatments,
which is a new type of method
that is used to cure disease.
And so we need to run
thousands of these simulations.
So as an example, if I wanted
to run 1,000 of these one
second simulations, I would
require 50,000 core hours,
one hour and 50,000 cores.
So this is a massive
amount of computing power
that is required.
And I want to show you
the evolution of how
I started using supercomputers.
We started with a university
cluster, which had 500 cores.
And this very quickly
showed it was very limited.
We then used an NSF
scientific shared cluster
with around 7,000 cores.
But it also turned out to be
not enough for our simulations.
And we have very recently
moved to Google Cloud, which
allows us to use up to
50,000 cores at the moment,
but you can actually use more.
And this translates just
as an example to show you
the amount of time required
to run these 1,000 brain
simulations.
So in the original, you
never see the cluster.
That would be over 120 hours.
In the scientific
shared cluster,
it would be over 30 hours.
And in Google Cloud, I
can just use one hour
to run all these simulations.
So this for me means
that I can speed up
my research enormously.
I can think of an
idea, a treatment,
design the simulation,
and test it
in just one hour, which
is really helpful for me.
So I just want to show you some
of the results illustrating
some of the results
obtaining these simulations.
So here we see in the
background our representation
of the motor cortex circuits.
And we see on the top-left,
the diffusion of calcium,
which is one of the molecules
used in synaptic plasticity.
So it's involved in learning,
in Alzheimer's, and we
can see how it diffuses
around the neuron.
We can also see the
electrical activity,
the spikes of the neuron, at the
bottom, which is the way that
neurons communicate.
And we can see two measures
of the statistics of how
populations fire
and the oscillations
of these populations.
These are related, for example,
to things like epilepsy.
So what are some
of the advantages
of using Google Cloud, in
particular compute engines,
which is what I used?
As I mentioned already, I have
virtually unlimited number
of nodes that I can use.
And I have no queues.
In most of the other
supercomputers,
there are queues of
over one or two days
before the jobs
actually start running.
The other advantages I can
deploy fully customized
clusters.
So I can build the cluster to
my requirements specifically,
which makes it very efficient.
And the cluster importantly
scales up automatically.
So as soon as I start
submitting jobs,
new nodes start lighting up.
And once they are-- the jobs
finished, they turn off.
So that makes it very efficient
and very cost-effective.
It is also integrated
with this alarm workload
manager, which allows you
to submit jobs very easily.
It allows to have several users
connect to the supercomputer
and submit jobs.
And it allowed me to reuse
some of that code, the scripts
that I had for previously
tools that I use using Slurm,
so I could just deploy
them and use them directly
in Google Cloud.
Finally, I'm also
using taking advantage
of these preemptible
nodes, which are basically
four times cheaper.
The disadvantage is
that they get preempted.
So they are taken away
around 10% of the time.
So to minimize the impact
of getting preempted,
we learned a couple of tricks.
In particular, if you balance
the duration of this simulation
and the number of cores you
use, by using less cores
you can minimize--
reduce the chance of these
nodes getting preempted.
You can also run during the
night, which is a simple trick,
and it means that less of
the jobs get preempted.
And you can also generate
scripts that automatically
resubmit that job so
that you don't have
to take into account where
some jobs finished or not
and they are just--
after some time that
will be completed.
So I just want to finish by
concluding that Google Cloud is
basically helping us understand
and treat brain disorders.
As I mentioned before,
these brain disorders
affect a large part
of the population.
And so there are many
promising lines of research now
that are happening.
And this space race for
understanding the brain
is just beginning.
So I think we can all look
forward to very exciting times
ahead.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
And I want to pass to Ben,
who's going to be talking
about investigating microbes.
BEN TORKIAN: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
I want to start my
talk with this quote,
"microbes run the world."
More than half of the
oxygen you're breathing
is generated by microbes.
More than half of
our body is microbe.
And studying the
microbial ecosystem
are key to our survival.
One of the material to study
microbial life is metagenomics.
Metagenomics-- we go and take
a sample from the environment
and trying to understand who is
there and what they are doing.
And this give us
a snapshot we can
try to gather and
understand what's
happening in that environment.
And our goal is to
collect as many snapshot
as possible to be able to
hopefully make a climate change
model.
And then we see how the
microbial life changing
as climate changing, because
that's going to be key for us.
In our study, we
actually go to the island
in Bahamas called San Salvador.
And you can see these islands
are really unique, because they
have many, many ponds.
And you can see the study pond--
the one we are doing our work
is marked with a red
arrow right there--
they are unique because
they are close to the ocean,
but they're a closed pond.
They are not open to the water.
They go through much rapid
climate change compared
to any other environment.
That enables us to observe the
climate change much faster.
And when we take
a sample, we can
have a better understanding of
how the climate change affects
our sample.
And we're trying to kind of
collect all this information
whenever we taking any samples
from this environments.
And I'm sure, same
Bahamas, that's
what you guys are thinking.
Yes, it's beautiful.
We really have fun going there.
But most times,
this is our views,
because these ponds are
so close to environment,
they go through really
harsh environment.
And in this pond, you can see
the salinity is really high.
The water turns yellow.
We saw even purple
or other colors,
depending on what happens
with that environment,
the color of water changing.
And that's really
interests us to see
what happens to those microbial
ecosystem in that environment.
And as mentioned, we go
there literally trying
to not disturb the
environment and trying
to pick up the sample,
then take the sample
to our lab trying to sequence
it and run our computation
to understanding what's
going on in our sample.
But still, we are dealing with
two main issue, one of them
are data getting
bigger and bigger.
I'm sure everybody here heard
the sequencing technology
getting cheaper and cheaper.
We're sequencing our
own DNA, our dogs now.
And we're getting
more and more data.
And really in our experiments
for each snapshot,
like 10 terabytes of data.
For this study we are working
on, we have 10 snapshot.
We're dealing with 100
terabytes of data to compute.
And that's a lot of
data to just go through.
Also, if you guys know by
Informatica [INAUDIBLE],,
they're computationally
expensive.
Everybody I'm sure heard
about assembly or alignment.
There have a lot of
optimization to these algorithm,
but still they are heavily
computationally expensive.
And there are not much we can
do but just compute the data.
As this data growing, the
compute time growing too.
What we try to do,
we come back and look
at our workflow in a lab.
And we understand the compute
time and analytic part
is the main part
we need to focus
in trying to solve the issue.
And what we kind of trying
to go our university cluster
and see what we
can do and change
our workflow to be able to
compute our data much faster.
We come up with
our own workflow.
We design our own workflow to
be able to scale up our job.
But if you're familiar
with the workflows,
the second you see this
picture, you should recall this.
This is MapReduce.
What we did we add up
the MapReduce model
to our workflow.
And you can see--
in the top, you can
mention all the parts
we are doing to our
workflow is in the top.
And you can see how it is
matched to the MapReduce.
And that was the
reason we thought,
oh, we solved the issue.
Now, we can scale
as much as we need.
But in reality, when
we done run our job,
we were really happy to see
the job was taken seven years
to change to 3 and 1/2 months.
But if you know research, most
times you have one or two year.
If you get a life
grant, it's five years.
And I mentioned we
have 10 snapshot.
In this case, we're going to
be around three months just
computing the data.
I don't know when they're
going to be able to actually
publish or do the work.
That was the reason we kind of
a reached our friend at Google
and asked them for help.
And we estimate, after
we transition to GCP,
we can finish the
same work in 12 hours.
That's a big deal.
I'm getting right
here to my friend
Paul to tell you guys
how we move our workflow
from our local cluster to GCP.
Thank you.
PAUL SAGONA: Hello.
All right.
No, that's all right.
Thanks, man.
Yeah, so as part of the
HPC team at the University
our job is to help them
accelerate their research.
And if we see that we can go
from seven years to half a day,
well, we need to
make that happen.
So our first step was
to come up with a plan.
We really wanted
to deploy a cluster
in the cloud that happened
to look like our environment
back home.
We wanted to dynamically
scale that environment based
on his job size or
future job sizes.
We also wanted to
dynamically install
a software stack based on the
software he needed or needed
to change and so on.
We also had to come up
with the best storage
solution, because we're
dealing with a lot of data.
And one mistake
could cost us a lot.
So next stage was
doing small test.
You know, we needed to
iterate through the process
to basically optimize, make
sure that we're doing this
exactly right or else
again it could cost us.
We had to develop tools
to basically script out
automated job submission
because of the large set of jobs
and samples that we
had to work with.
After we did that, we're able
to scale up to smaller just
to make sure our
scaling is working right
before we have to
send out that big job.
And then lastly, that big job,
we have to hit the go button,
submit the entire
work set, monitor
and verify that these results
are coming back right.
So this is what our solution
ended up looking like.
And you know, you
can kind of think
of In this as our input,
our compute, and our output.
Now, our input is our reference
database, which is actually
going to be the same for
every job that we run
and then of course,
our sample database.
We ended up using an
attached persistent SSD
for this entire run.
Every job had this
attached persistent SSD,
but the key was
it was read only.
This worked extremely
well for us.
It was fast and
scaled extremely well.
Our compute-- so our compute
is our dynamic HPC cluster.
And as I said, I wanted this
to look like our cluster
back home.
So it does.
We have a login node,
a controller node,
and our compute stack.
Our compute stack ended
up being the 32 core
instances out there.
Now, this is all managed with
a Slurm workload manager.
So as mentioned in
the previous talk,
our jobs actually
scaled with the cluster.
So it worked out great.
Our output-- so our outputs
are actually relatively small.
And you know, we didn't
really need a big scale SSDs,
big scale file storage.
We actually sent our data
at the end of our jobs
to a Google Cloud bucket.
So the job-- we ran on a
124,352 cores concurrently.
We ran on 303,886 nodes.
And we did that in
16 and 1/2 hours.
So challenges and
findings for our run,
it was enormously successful.
I think we had two
instances where
the nodes didn't come up right.
We resubmitted those
jobs automatically
through our scheduler.
It worked great.
During the testing
phase, as I mentioned,
we had to find
that best storage.
We tried NFS.
We tried one of the Elastifile
file-- which was neat,
but kind of overkill--
and tried some
local disk options.
And you know, we ended up
going with that combination
of the local SSD and connected
to that persisted SSD.
It worked great.
Slurm-- so Slurm
was a lot of fun.
You know, we used the term
workload manager back home
on our cluster.
So we were already
very familiar.
Working with the Google
team and the Slurm team,
we went through a
lot of tweaking,
a lot of making it
just how we wanted.
Lastly, something we didn't
anticipate is hyper-threading.
In our HPC space and
in most HPC shops,
we don't use hyper-threading.
It just doesn't
provide any advantage.
It's already enabled
in the cloud.
So that actually affected
our runtime slightly.
So it's just something for us
to keep in mind in the future.
So our takeaway and
our key next steps,
this greatly, greatly
enhanced our research.
I mean, it really made this
a reality for this lab.
Our collaborative process
with the Google team
and the Slurm's SchedMD
team was fantastic.
You know, we provided feedback.
They provide suggestions.
I think we actually led to
some code changes, and updates,
and things like that.
My goal even before this
and still moving forward
is us to locally burst our
environment into cloud.
And this is exactly what it was.
So we're really looking
forward to the future.
And now that this has
been-- this particular one
has been a success
for this research lab,
that lab is now able
to seek further funding
and able to expand the research.
You know, climate change
doesn't happen in a day.
He needs samples for
months, years, even decades.
So he already has about a year's
worth of data ready to compute.
And if he's tried
to continue what
he was doing on his local PC,
it would take him 50 years,
just for a year's
worth of data--
on our cluster, 2.2 years--
and that's if I actually
let him on my cluster
for 2.2 years dedicated--
GCP 3 and 1/2 days.
I'd like to thank Bob Doran--
he's another member
or a group that
made this project possible--
Shawn Norman-- who is the
lead PI for the research--
and of course our Google team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]